- okay you can see how does really fit
with other things you look they're like
what is this it's one series but you
currently do much with it while its own
slime they pee there's no common
difference as long a GP is no common
ratio what do we have to do in there as
is implied by the name what would you do
yeah break apart consider it has two
different sequences okay so what I'm
going to do is have a think of the first
series we call it series a and you could
take either part just to be own just to
be alphabetical I'm gonna take the 1 3 5
7 5 okay so I would say here and I'm
going to try and do my sitting out here
the way that I expect right series a is
an AP right as there is a common
difference
okay now yeah Chris on the question will
tell you the question metal often we get
questions like this all they're really
asking for is give me the general term
for the whole thing or give me the the
general some for the n in number of
terms right so it's not it's a lot of
proof kind of thing sometimes I'll say
it nor do you like multiple parts and
say prove that this part is this and
that how is that but usually not okay
I'm not doing this just so that you know
what you're doing and what you've got is
not just a mess of numbers which you're
like what is this about what was the
logic now before I leave off this and
have a look at the second part of it
let's work out what are the pieces of
information that led to this AP okay so
it's Tuesday is an arithmetic
progression with what's the first term
one and a common difference of two okay
so that's all I need really to work out
my general or my intern and like all my
general way and in terms
so therefore what was the general form
which we revised yesterday for the nth
term of an AP it's the first term plus
one lot were less lots of the common
difference okay so all I'm gonna do is
just submit that's it this is not hard
okay why the plus the N stays right
because this is in terms of n but the
rest I can replace
so there's my simplified way I can now
do the series some in the same way what
was out for now figure out slowing you
got two different forms for calculating
the Sun or an athletic progression
reaches the most convenient one yeah
they both start within or two but then
there's something different thank you I
can go to a plus and minus one D right
they'll be fine however that n minus one
D part right where does it come from
it comes from here it comes from last
term right which I've already worked out
this is the nth term this is um what if
you like this is the L the last term in
the series right so see I already know
what that is I might as well just save
myself some effort say that's first plus
last and on two we already know what is
all right now that you're done with this
you can repeat for series B okay the
second part
and I think you guys could probably take
it from here all right I want to come up
with the info I wanna come up with the
the sum of the first n terms of the
second part of the series now when I'm
considering the composit series the
whole lot what will I do if I want T of
M and s MN of the original series I'll
take that TM and this TN right once I've
gone there and I don't know that's it
and in the same way I'll try and work
out the sum of the whole lot I'll take
both of these sums and I'll add them up
that's all
okay now in this case it's a compass a
series between an AP and a GP I propose
to questions to what happens what
happens when you take a compass it all
about to AP's if you already know the
answer this is don't shatter now what
would you get as a clock ensues that
what would you have to do okay in the
same way if I gave you two GPS as a
comedy series what would happen what
would that seriously look like what
would you have to do with that okay
so there are my two questions as well as
finish this off have a think about them
and then we'll come back in a few
minutes